non-minimalists
i have made a few lifestyle changes that
have really helped me mentally
emotionally and physically
but i still find myself having what i
call bad mental health days where i
start questioning my abilities and lose
hope of myself
i feel stuck and it gets really hard to
get out of that pessimistic mentality
i was wondering if you guys have days
like that and if you do how do you deal
with them
how do you get out of your own head and
find the motivation and positivity to
keep pushing forward
nicole let's talk to diana about first i
hear this value judgment right at the
beginning i have these bad mental health
days
which presupposes there are good mental
health days and bad mental health days
i suspect you don't look at it that way
i actually
urge and suggest us all to redevelop a
new habit of not
passing judgment period getting rid of
good bad
should shouldn't another judgment we
love to cast upon ourselves so yes
simple answer
be as objective as possible things are
as they are
yes yeah so what do you tell someone
like if diana were to come to you
and and talk to you about the pessimism
that she's feeling these
uh these bad mental health days uh what
how would you try to help her unpack
this
so peeling back the layer and we'll call
it distress right there's distress
i'm having a distressing day a stressful
day not bad
the first thing i would offer is it's
normal
right i think a lot of us think and i
think probably i was this person at one
time we have some expectation
of one feeling state forever more and we
just
that isn't what human is human we have a
breath of feelings the positive lack for
lack of a better
word end of the spectrum a negative so
there's fluctuation
we need to learn how to have a stressful
thing happen metabolize the stress
become stressed in our bodies if you
will and then return to baseline so the
first offering i would make
is that variation in our human
experiences around our emotions
is normal so any of us that are thinking
we're going to avoid the more
distressing side of emotions
isn't the case with that said we can
really begin to understand
the role we're playing in terms of our
emotional world and what i mean when i
say that
is you know if you are someone so diana
right maybe i
know that i ruminate maybe i can see
that first negative train of thinking oh
today's a no good very bad day then i
just keep repeating that
throughout the day the longer you repeat
for lack of a better word again a
negative thought
the more chances that you're going to
have a body reaction
so we want to pay attention to how much
attention we're paying to our thinking
minds
because a lot of us continue to color
our experiences with the negativity i
could be that person
i wake up i have one negative thought
and if i'm not careful
i continue down a snow plow of negative
thoughts and before i know it by 12 pm
i feel negative so becoming aware
and we can't stop our thoughts that's
something i want to offer right here
right now i think this is a good
teaching moment
so don't beat ourselves up about the
thoughts that you're witnessing in our
mind
we want to learn how to give them less
attention meaning we can't shut them off
we all wish we could
when that first thought comes so if it
is a negative
thought if you will we want to practice
removing our
attention and the best place to put our
attention
to kind of piggyback what we were just
talking about consciousness
is in the current moment so we can use
our senses what am i seeing touching
tasting
feeling can i focus on what i'm feeling
in this moment
instead of my maybe negative based
thought patterns
yeah i remember uh one time i missed
this phone call with
a man that i had set up a specific time
to talk to him uh i was like two hours
late to it
and i felt so horrible and i was talking
to him and he could tell he's like dude
you're really stressed out about this
aren't you and i'm like yeah man like
this is
something that shows up in my life and
uh yeah like i made this commitment to
you i feel really bad that i broke it
and he was like if you want to uh earn
my forgiveness he's like i want you to
be kind to yourself
about this he's like that is that is a
how you can be forgiven by me but it was
the best advice
that i ever got because now when i find
myself having these bad days which
i do i have a lot of them instead of
getting caught in that spiral of
self-doubt or that self-judgment
um i try to talk to myself a little bit
kinder even if i screw up something
instead of beating myself up it's a
matter of like okay what can i learn
from this how can i
how can i be kind to myself through this
negative emotion
uh one of the best pieces of advice that
i've ever had what do you think about
like
physical activities when someone is
feeling down for me
i know like sometimes just going on a
walk will help me feel a little bit
better getting out in the sun
um exercising like if i can just get on
i have an exercise bike if i could get
on there for like 20 minutes i know that
i feel so much different afterwards
these aren't like miracle cures but they
are
uh they help they definitely help but
does does that
play a role at all with with these bad
days 100
i mean part of holistic is acknowledging
the connection between the mind and the
body so just as much as we're all
talking about
right my thoughts and i think most
listeners have that experience i think
it's stressful thought
my body starts to release stress
hormones my heart rate might start to
increase i might
tense my body is sending messages to my
mind
so for some of us and this is where it's
really individualized which is why you'd
never hear me proclaim universally
everyone do this when we're sad or this
one we're angry
because we all are different
energetically yeah a lot of us
though movement even gentle gentle
stretching just moving we have energies
coursing through our body
at all times breathing walking it
doesn't have to be something strenuous
i know a lot of us are compromised
physically
however discharging our energy
physically can go a long way
to calm our body and then the signal
that our the message our mind will begin
to get
is one that's somewhat calmer than that
agitated energy so i'm like you i've
learned very begrudgingly so
that especially when i'm what i label as
agitated and that's gonna be different
for everyone else but what i've come to
know my body is in
agitation unfortunately i have to get
and take the walk
do the movement it's might be the last
thing i want to do
but again i just want to reiterate it's
very individualized this isn't me saying
everyone go out and have a run
when you're upset because someone else
that might not help their energy feel
more balanced that's what most of us are
looking for the discharge of energy
that's agitated
and allowing us to return back to
balance i love that idea of the
discharging of energy because with diana
here it sounds like
she's looking for a way to fix these
days and there isn't
there is no fix it is a matter of how
are you
dealing with these symptoms how are you
letting it pass through you so to speak
this energy
um instead of looking for a way to block
it it's diana maybe you want to ask
yourself
how can i let this energy flow through
me how can i discharge that energy
i love that too because you're really
highlighting something else which i get
just quickly
a lot of times a lot of talk about
bypassing right and and this isn't just
about think the happy thought diana or
anyone listening right it is actually
like you said about
releasing it to allow it to go a lot of
us get very good at stuffing it
yeah right that's not actually releasing
it so it's not just grab onto the next
happy thought and hold on to it until
you're happy again
for a lot of us it's find that release
for the negative crap
so that i can free up my energy to
return to balance to then
elevate into the more positive end so
just to be clear on that because i know
a lot of
some of us can listen to that and hear
oh bypassing don't ever focus and
i appreciate that you highlight it the
importance of letting the negative be
yeah i love what you're saying there
there is no fix there's only change
right if i were to make it a pithy
little maxim there yeah
and because we are and what i love about
what you're talking about here nicole is
you're not offering
the prescription you know it's not the
seven step plan to be happy
right because we've tried all of those
and they haven't worked out for us
very well right we've tried the steps
and
momentarily through chasing pleasure or
chasing happiness
we've achieved it momentarily but of
course it's always ephemeral and then
we're always let down because
oh wait i didn't achieve the state of
perpetual pleasure well it's because
that state doesn't
exist and the problem here
is actually the the the solutions are
are
turned into the problem people like
diana and myself
and most of us we seek out the the fix
right and by seeking out the fix in many
cases it actually makes us more
discontent doesn't it